[Música]
como a tecnologia pode mudar as nossas
vidas como a pesquisa a inovação pode
mudar nossas vidas
meu nome é laerson seu professor do
instituto federal goiano diretor do pólo
de inovação do instituto
quero aqui hoje falar sobre as nossas
experiências no desenvolvimento de
tecnologias para a agricultura e como
isso vem contribuindo para a formação de
nossos alunos e como isso faz a
diferença na formação e no mercado de
trabalho desenvolveu então com a através
do conhecimento em c em fitopatologia e
sensoriamento remoto a nossa equipe eu
trabalho trabalhamos no desenvolvimento
de tecnologias sensores embarcados que
possam ser acoplados é em drones aviões
e que esses sensores possam captar
informações lá da lavoura e permite que
a gente faça o uso sustentável desses é
fungicidas e herbicidas que busca então
o equilíbrio porque se você detecta que
existem plantas doentes você tem que
aplicar naquele local e não em toda a
área e hoje o que se faz na agricultura
por restrições quando se tem algumas
plantas doentes você aplica em toda a
área e com o que nós desenvolvemos lá
hoje nós conseguimos é fazer aplicações
localizadas direcionadas para a
agricultura
bom eu quero pedir um pouco a licença
vocês para voltar que alguns anos atrás
para que eu possa é e simplificar como a
pesquisa como a inovação como é a
tecnologia mudou a minha vida
e aí obviamente no final eu quero
mostrar pra vocês também como nós
fazemos lá no if goiano pra que essas
tecnologias para que esse conhecimento
mude a vida
nossos alunos porque a gente precisa
dessa revolução a gente precisa permitir
isso aos nossos alunos
bom há muitos anos lá no início é passei
toda a minha infância na fazenda muito
espaço muitas brincadeiras
mas o que mais me agradava o que eu mais
adorava fazer a desmontar as coisas
eu adorava desmontar nem sempre voltava
a funcionar mas eu adorava fazer aquilo
e aí um dia eu tiver a oportunidade há
aquele carrinho ele foi um carrinho que
eu ganhei de um primo meu que já não
usava mais aquele aquele que lhe
brinquedo era grande e pra mim foi algo
assim que marcou a minha infância porque
esse caminho que eu não sei nem dizer
quantas vezes eu desmontei e remontei
ele pra criar algo diferente mas era
algo que eu amava fazer gostado muito
além da obra acima a gente tem um
carrinho pedal kate que a gente chama
mas é um é simplesmente um carro movido
a pedal mas aquilo também é uma diversão
tremenda mas aí um dia eu estava lá só
imaginando olha como é que eu vou fazer
pra isso aqui fica diferente é preciso
mudar isso aqui
isso aqui tá bacana mas pode ficar
melhor e aí eu pensei foi olha posso
pegar um motor colocar aqui nesse
carrinho e eu vou fazer ele ficar
motorizado vai ficar muito bacana a
gente vai brincar muito
fui lá escondido peguei a a um motor a
motosserra que meu pai tinha lá os
equipamentos escondido foi lá desmontei
estou da gambiarra no meio do processo
eu parei e falei meu deus se eu não
acertar isso aqui meu pai me tornei me
colocar de castigo e eu vou sofrer
vários problemas aqui com ele com essa
ação e aí eu tive que me dedicar muito
para fazer dar certo e e meu pai não
podia descobrir nesse meio do caminho
fez tudo muito ali debaixo do quieto mas
no final eu tive muita sorte deu certo e
eu consegui adaptar e me livrei do
castigo a outra coisa bacana é
divertimos muito entre nós amigos primos
com esse carinho aí e é e essas
adaptações bom no período de escola na
infância eu só tirava nota boa mas não
era por acaso
minha mãe trabalhava na mesma escola que
eu então não podia vacilar ali porque
senão ela tava de imediato puxando minha
orelha então eu sempre fui um aluno
razoável e bem mas aí eu fui pro 2º grau
e eu tinha duas opções ou eu ficava em
caturaí porque eu sou eu sou da cidade
de caturaí estudaria a noite ou então eu
iria pra em umas que ama outra cidade lá
prós e que teria o ensino médio já na já
no período de manhã no matutino e aí a
minha mãe muito esperta muito
inteligente muito sábia e já e já
antecipou o lance ou aécio for fazer a
agradar a alguns ensino médio lá na no
período noturno eu tenho certeza que ele
vai se perder ali naquelas naquelas
noites ali e eu não pensava diferente eu
queria me perder aquelas noite porque é
óbvio que o que a gente quer naquele
período
a gente quer brincar a gente quer curtir
a vida e não necessariamente pensa
talvez nas consequências de que isso
pode trazê-la para frente então ela
estava certíssima e ela me colocou no
caminho fui fazer a escola lá em umas no
período matutino para evitar qualquer
risco
bom mas óbvio que em qualquer lugar a
gente está sujeito a situações há
oportunidades que podem tirar a gente do
caminho que a gente quer seguir é e aí
então eu fui cursar e aí novas
experiências novos amigos comecei a ter
uma percepção um pouco mais ampla de que
dentro de uma sala de aula a gente tem
amigos
não importa qual sala sempre vai ter
aquele nerd sempre vai ter o fundão
sempre vai ter a minha galera do meio
que está ali tentando mas tem muita
dificuldade
eu particularmente era essa galera do
meio aí que estava tentando ali
conseguir passar no ano sem precisar de
recuperação mas e aí
é eu eu queria contar um outra
oportunidade que foi pra mim muito
chocante e que realmente mostra que o
que é o que eu quero falar é às vezes a
gente está vivo é porque existe uma
força maior que realmente quer que a
gente fique ali vivo naqueles naqueles
momentos em um desses momentos lá na
escola
tinha um amigo um colega que ele tinha
um jeito peculiar
ele queria mostrar a capacidade bélica
que ele tinha vocês querem 166 entender
mas ele gostava de levar armas para
dentro da escola para se exibir e
mostrar que ele era liu valentão daquela
daquela daquele pedaço
todo dia ele levava algo diferente um
dia ele levou um 38 pra sala de aula
mostrou livros coleguinhas e eu fiquei
de longe que o movimento de água e aí
nesse dia é ele queria mostrar não só
para nós e queria mostrar para a sala
inteira e se exibe a professora saiu
rapidamente para executar alguma coisa
fora e ele não é mais rápida ainda pegou
a mochila foi lá pra frente e é em
questão de alguns segundos tirou a arma
do tirol a arma da mochila apontou pra
todo mundo todo mundo ficou assim ele
perguntou vocês já brincavam de roleta
russa
todo mundo entrou em pânico e desespero
e ele bateu a mão e começou a fazer
assim foi o momento mais assustador que
eu passei naquele momento naquele
naquela naquela escola mas fim da
história eu não pude falar nada ninguém
falou nada porque a ameaça era é muito
alto mas olham só como a gente pode
passar por momentos que colocam a vida
em risco a gente está repleto de
informações dizendo que houve tiroteio
que eu vi aqui no o piloto e há muitos
anos atrás isso também acontecia e
realmente a gente sobrevive é também
graças a uma força maior que manterá
agentes naquele local naquele local
mas o que ficou de aprendizado desse
desse desse trauma é que a gente teve
aquele pé naquele período é que o
seguinte é que a gente vê muitos muitas
pessoas que têm uma capacidade muito
grande e são inteligentes que tenham
habilidade artística a fantástica eu
tinha amigos que desenhavam uma
perfeição que tinha um poder da
matemática muito bem mas eu via ele
saindo da escola perdendo os perdendo
aquela oportunidade por falta por
problemas financeiros problemas
familiares e isso me entristecia muito
porque eu vi o potencial daquele
caras que eu não era lá aquelas coisas
mas eu via aqueles caras bons em viana
eles ficando pra trás mas aí é que eu
comecei a ter o meu propósito que eu
posso fazer para mudar a realidade que é
que eu posso fazer para trazer a
oportunidade para essas pessoas e elas
não poderem não perderem o seu caminho e
sem poder contribuir com o crescimento
da sociedade
bom nesse período eu sair da
universidade
já tava assim bem é desculpa eu saí do
ensino médio e buscando a universidade
mas aí a pergunta era como é que eu vou
fazer o que eu aprendi para poder passar
num da universidade
e aí eu fui escolher também qual era a
minha capacidade nem a minha competência
o que eu queria fazer para o resto da
vida
bom pra mim essa resposta não foi tão
difícil porque eu sempre gostei de
tecnologia eu sempre gostei de trabalhar
ali com essa parte de automação e em
forma geral era o que eu gostava e o que
eu queria mesmo então optei pelas
condições que a gente tinha aqui na
região em goiás
eu tenho de engenharia elétrica é cara
levei pau só foi fazer reúnem paulo
porque é a minha formação
infelizmente não foi adequada e eu
precisei perder dois anos aí pra
reconstruir um conhecimento e para que
eu fosse é passar a pé para a
universidade
e aí nesse momento de alegria que eu já
tinha passado na universidade estava lá
festejando a chega um tio meu respeito
demais
ele chegou para mim e falou assim ah és
parabéns mas te digo uma coisa entrar e
fácil eu quero ver você sair com o
diploma porque aí sim você vai estar
fazendo a diferença na sua vida
não eu tô aqui comemorando e é possível
que vai piorar ele foi tão difícil gasta
em dois anos a entrar aqui não vai
piorar falar nada piorou muito e chorou
muito piorou muito porque era muito
difícil a universidade o ritmo é
diferente você tem que estar mais
engajado a o curso que eu passei foi
agronomia
aí o pessoal fala mas o seu sonho não o
meu sonho não morreu
eu procurei outras formas de fazer isso
acontecer porque agronomia também uma
forma de engenharia por que não eu
pudesse me especializar em uma área de
engenharia para um ano de agronomia bom
o curso integral bastante pesado difícil
é e eu ainda morava longe eu tinha eu
tinha 56 pilotos de caminho cortava 4
horas da manhã e ia pra pra capturar e
pegar um ônibus
esse ônibus e ia para a cidade lá em
goiânia de goiânia pegar outro ônibus
chegava na universidade seis e meia da
manhã estava na universidade ela
começava 768 ficar esperando as coisas
acontecerem ajudava ali o pessoal abriu
os portões porque eu era o primeiro a
chegar ali mas isso tudo só começou a
melhorar quando eu fui fazer estágio
primeira oportunidade que eu tive de
estágio e aí eu comecei a falar cara é
aqui que o negócio vai acontecer porque
eu conseguia verificar que o aaa à
técnica ea técnica que estava fazendo e
eu ajudava ali ia gerar um produto e
gerar uma solução e aquilo fazia aquela
teoria chata que às vezes eu via lá se
tornem realidade falei cara isso é muito
massa é isso aqui que eu quero fazer mas
o meu estágio era e processamento mínimo
de guariroba gente não tinha nada a ver
com o meu sonho mais cara
graças ao meu irmão um cara que também
tinha uma formação muito boa me orientou
fala olha aproveite o máximo mesmo que
não seja a sua formação aproveite
aproveite essa oportunidade porque isso
pode contribuir com o seu futuro e assim
fiz o máximo pra contribuir
melhorei meu currículo fiz várias
publicações linhas ali e mm preparei pra
qualquer outra situação que pudesse
surgir um dia passando a se passar nos
corredores da universidade olhei no
painel oportunidade de graduação
sanduíche
é graduação sanduíche na frança com tudo
pago
graça de graça falei cara essa é a
oportunidade para melhorar o meu
currículo para ter uma experiência
bacana
se eu soubesse falar francês
eu não sabia falar francês e aí como é
que eu ia fazer uma baita oportunidade
falei não vou tentar aprender estudar
cada dinheiro pra fazer cursinho não
tinha dinheiro
chamei meu irmão foi embora me ajuda eu
quero aprender francês e eu tenho seis
meses para aprender porque o processo
seletivo é daqui seis meses
peguei dedicar a estudar e aí eu baixar
não posso pode podcast fazia ou via
tentava transcrevê escrevia fazer de
tudo pra aprender e aí eu tinha um ou
outro probleminha e eu tinha que
resolver
na época eu estava namorando tinha
acabado de memória começa a namorar e eu
estava convencendo a minha namorada aí
fazer francês também para quem sabe aí
comigo mas o pior e convenceu souber
sogra ela deixar eu ir junto caminha com
a minha namorada pra lá não foi muito
fácil mas é é a o aprendizado do francês
um certo momento eu falei cara não vai
dar eu não tenho condições de t é
proficiência pra isso e aí o meu pai que
não tem informação nenhuma
mas é o segundo grau mas uma pessoa
muito simples mas que eu tenho como
muito sábio ele nem um dia desses que o
desanimado ele chegou e falou à s
não estude para ser bom
fez tudo para ser o melhor faça o seu
melhor seja o melhor porque a gente boa
tem muito e ele não estava tão errado
assim eu esperei na hora que ele falou
isso falei cara eu sou um cara do meio
como é que eu vou fazer o seu melhor e
aí que eu comecei a depois de um tempo
comecei a entender o que ele queria
dizer é faça o seu melhor
faça o seu melhor naquela oportunidade
porque pode ser que não tenha outra e
aquilo possa fazer a diferença na sua
vida
e aí eu fiquei desesperado naquele
momento fez piorar a situação mas depois
eu consegui entender qual era a a
perspectiva que ele estava me passando
bons momentos do sul
which fui para a frança cheguei lá
piorou ainda mais
era mais difícil ainda eu estava na aula
de bioquímica
é ouvindo explicações sobre reações de
maior de outras reações de canalização
em francês
eu estava com a cabeça quase explodindo
porque há o meu conhecimento era um
conhecimento de um produto de um de um
aluno que estudou seis meses ali na
marra para conseguir passar e consegui a
proficiência então foi um momento de
muito stress
mas aí vem o ponto principal que fez
realmente a revolução e eu achei o
caminho na minha vida foi quando eu fui
fazer um estágio e uma cooperativa
agrícola chamada grupo occitan é um
grupo na frança no sul da frança em que
eu fui contratado como estagiário pra
ajudar a coletar informações de canto
jogar isso em planilhas coletar
informações de estações meteorológicas
jogar isso numa planilha e alimentar um
sistema de simulação de previsão de
risco de doenças
então é um sistema que alerta dizendo
olha tem 99% de chance de tal doença ou
seja o agricultor tem que entrar fazendo
algum manejo para resolver o problema
quando eu tive o primeiro contato com
isso eu falei cara é isso que eu quero
fazer é isso que eu quero para minha
vida eu quero tecnologia eu sou agrônomo
eu estou formando com maroni e é essa
tecnologia que eu quero inteligência
artificial uso de tecnologia que possa
agregar e possa ajudar o agricultor lá
na lavoura foi então esse período o mais
difícil foi muito difícil porque a gente
eu tinha o meu francês básico ele vivia
tudo bem conseguir passar em todas as
disciplinas que eu fiz não fiquei
nenhuma mas gente falar com o francês já
não é de que não é fácil e falar com o
francês lado interior com o sotaque
violento gente é o fim e eu falava às
vezes por telefone
eu lembro de várias vezes desligar o
telefone que eu não tinha entendido que
o cara tinha falado que eu ia no meu
chefe falava jeff sabbag fullana eu não
entendi o que ele falou
aí falou dela lá eu sei o que ele pegava
o telefone
gava e resolvi mas assim e aí nesses
momentos difíceis eu lembrava aquela
mensagem do meu pai faça não para ser
bom faça para ser melhor
faça o seu melhor e é pra isso que a
gente tem que está antenado quando for
fazer alguma coisa faz o seu melhor e eu
tenho certeza que você vai colher os
frutos de fazer o melhor na sua vida
bom voltei para o brasil imediatamente
fui para a embrapa fazer estágio e tive
uma oportunidade já de imediato o
mestrado
o mestrado tive a orientação do doutor
murilo da embrapa um cara excepcional
cara fantástico com a mente muito aberta
muito antenado sempre com publicações
muito boas encara referência
acho que todo mundo aqui já ouviu falar
que é você a média das cinco pessoas que
você vive certa cara eu queria ser a
média naquele cara e pra mim estar
próximo dele era uma sensação muito
bacana porque a cada vez que eu tocava
em uma conversa com ele é um aprendizado
a mais e isso me satisfazia
e aí eu estava trabalhando na época um
controle biológico de doenças de plantas
talvez falar mas de novo fora e da linha
não mas eu estava naquele ambiente
porque é ele é aquele ambiente era muito
favorável porque eu queria fazer lá na
frente e favorável porque eu queria
fazer lá no doutorado ea então no
doutorado
eu tive deixei tudo já muito organizado
falei não agora eu vou fazer exatamente
o que eu quero
e aí procurei o orientador na unb
um cara também excepcional fantástico
que ele cara de aquela pessoa com a
mente jovem aberta nova tecnologia
abertas novas soluções
minha me acolheu de braços abertos um
cara muito fantástico e me ensinou uma
coisa que na vida a gente como
profissional a gente precisa ser
problemas ou ver você tem que ser o cara
que resolve o problema
você não tem que ser o cara que traz o
problema do seu chefe ou para sua
empresa ou para onde você tá cara seja a
pessoa que resolva já traz a solução
traz ali eu tenho certeza que você vai
estar fazendo um
boa contribuição e isso foi a principal
a que o principal ganho que eu tive na
na vivência com esse meu professor
doutor de orientar e doutorado foi
problema sobre o cara seja problema
sobre e aí tive a oportunidade a amia na
minha tese foi trabalhar com modelagem e
simulação de risco de doenças
eu trabalhei com o mofo branco é uma
doença talvez que você não conheça mas é
uma doença muito importante mas é aí eu
eu me eu me preparei todo busquem junto
com o meu orientador bolsa para fazer
doutorado fora para trabalhar com cara
de referência no mundo com simulação de
risco e eu consegui essa bolsa já estava
tudo certinho e aí quando chegou no
quando chegou é mais no meio do ano
surgiu o concurso do if goiano fala cara
agora é a oportunidade às vezes vou
fazer a minha esposa apresentou para mim
eu falei não vou fazer eu vou sair do
meu sonho eu não quero sair do meu sonho
é mulher sabe como é que é conseguiu me
convencer obviamente a fazer aquele
concurso mas graças a ela eu fiz esse
concurso porque hoje eu estou no if
goiano e conseguir passar no processo
seletivo porque eu tentei porque a minha
justificativa pra ela foi
eu não vou conseguir eu não tenho nem
doutorado ainda eu estou no segundo ano
do doutorado e lá naquele concurso vai
ter doutor vai ter pós doutor e não tem
chance nenhuma de eu fazer eu consegui
passar o destino acaba mudando muitas
coisas e fazendo a gente caía mais
pegadinhas e essa foi muito boa porque
eu conseguir passar nesse processo bom
pra finalizar
eu entrei no ief eu tinha duas opções
entrar no if goiano a seguir no meu
sonho do doutorado e aí é que de novo
vem aquele sentimento de gratidão
gratidão à instituição que tem uma visão
pra frente que pensa investe naquelas
pessoas que estão ali dentro da
instituição
porque quando eu fui conversar com o
pessoal lá com os diretores da
instituição eles falaram à efe entre a
instituição e nós vamos liberar aí fazer
o doutorado de acordo
o que você quer cara pra mim foi a a
solução dos problemas que eu tinha um
concurso e eu poderia sair pra finalizar
meu doutorado e assim foi cumprido
sou extremamente grata à instituição e
hoje muitas das ações que eu faço é para
retribuir o que a instituição investiu
em mim o que era investir um tempo e
recurso pra que eu pudesse depois trazer
esse benefício
então hoje eu faço parte de uma equipe
que é do lado do eu faço parte do pólo
de inovação que são pesquisadores
focados no desenvolvimento de
tecnologias aplicada algo focado e aí
essa equipe hoje 15 profissionais entre
técnicos e professores pessoas também
excepcionais que trazem respostas para a
sociedade
mas o mais bacana é aquela turminha aí ó
é a primeira do laboratório que eu tô o
laboratório de drones na agricultura eo
da área de fitopatologia são hoje 28
pessoas entre os professores
orientadores e os nossos alunos são 28
pessoas que têm oportunidade que talvez
outros não teriam ou não teria se a
gente não tivesse ali agindo fazendo
gerando conhecimento esses alunos ajudam
a desenvolver as soluções ajudam a
resolver problemas e aí aquela teoria
que é chata lá na escola se torne uma
prática bacana lá dentro do laboratório
de drones se torne uma prática bacana
dentro do laboratório de fitopatologia
então hoje eu posso dizer que eu eu amo
o que eu faço e eu faço o que eu amo e o
que é mais gratificante porque é
cansativo mas o que é gratificante de
tudo isso é saber que eu posso
contribuir para que esses alunos aqui
possam crescer possam se beneficiar
possam desenvolver tecnologia possam
ajudar a sociedade
então essa é a contribuição que o if
goiano consegue fazer através da sua
equipe
e aí nós temos hoje mais um último
desafio nosso que é avançar para um
próximo nível é desenvolver um centro de
referência em tecnologia agroindustrial
que é um parque sentir
o tecnológico para que os alunos estejam
ali dentro
junto com as empresas com as suas
startup com as suas ideias desenvolvendo
tecnologia para a sociedade para trazer
o retorno que a sociedade precisa então
a minha dedicação hoje ea minha
gratificar minha amiga gratificação é
ver esses meus alunos tendo acesso a
informações que talvez não teria em
outra oportunidade
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]